[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this week on
you made it weird it is the incredible
Rami Youssef from his hit show Rami
which you have to check out here is a
little here's a little here's a little
taste online culture is to me it's like
for all of the parody of Christianity or
of religion or whatever we operate from
a very Christian standpoint which is
like hey look what this person tweeted
in 2012 they are now no longer ever able
to write or eat at any restaurant right
so it's like that that to me is like
like that's those are what's tries those
are Witch Trials that's what that is you
know what I'm doing gonna say it is it's
hell it's hell you send them to hell you
send them to hell you're doing it and
you sort of love it because if the evil
is over there it's not it's not you like
you're doing it that's what I mean I'm
thrill when people are like did you hear
about I'm like Oh you mean why don't you
just take it's not us it's not me but
it's like half the time I'm like I see
the way these conversations go out and
it's someone who I know like hates
really religion and I just want to be
like you're a Christian
guys I'm so excited that we finally got
to sit down we only have a few Pete's
picks if you guys want to support the
show one way you can do it is try the
Apollo neuro this is something that I
absolutely absolutely swear by it has
changed my life for the better I I have
it here as you can see I'm in a hotel
I'm on the road it's hard for me to
unwind after shows and Apollo neuro is a
wearable piece of technology that sends
almost sub-perceptual vibrations into
your nervous system help you cope with
stress it's basically like a wearable
hug for your nervous system that speaks
the language of your nervous system so
it can tell you to calm down after my
show last night I put on a setting
called rebuild and recover it just helps
your body recover that much faster it
helps you lull it into a more sedated
Stressless beautiful easy place I also
use that same setting after say like a
visit with my parents do something like
that I put on energy and wake up when I
want to work out sometimes social and
open when I'm doing stand-up like I was
last night here in Portland which was a
great show thanks to everybody that came
out helps you relax sleep focus and be
more productive it is not woo-woo I
always like to point this out it is made
by a neuroscientist and a board
certified psychiatrist who've been
studying the impacts of chronic stress
in humans for nearly 15 years and the
settings are energy and wake up Social
and open clear and focus which has been
proven to help people with symptoms of
ADD to dial in whenever I'm writing I
got this thing rocking unclear in Focus
rebuild and recover which we covered
meditation and mindfulness which gets my
meditation no joke so deep the first
time I used the Apollo while I was
meditating I was like is this thing
meditating for me if it only helps with
meditation I would still be shouting as
Praises from the rooftops but it also
helps with relax and unwind and last
night as I was sleeping here in the
hotel can be weird sleeping in a new
place I've put on sleep and renew which
gently lulls you to sleep it is
incredible it's such a great way to have
nothing going into your system but
something on your system that can speak
to your nervous system and help you cope
with stress pause effects on stress
sleep cognitive cognitive performance
and Recovery have been proven in
multiple clinical trials and real world
studies and the more you use it this is
the best part the better it works so you
can get 10 off try an Apollo neuro it's
shame I met a lot of weirdos several of
them were wearing a pause and they told
me that it changed their life as well
give it a try show your support of the
show and you can get 10 off by going to
apollonuro.com weird that's Apollo
n-euro.com weird for 10 off and show
your support of the show alright guys I
do have some more tour dates too if you
want to come and see me go to
petehomes.com or see me once a month in
Los Angeles at Largo go to largo-la.com
for tickets to that in the meantime time
enjoy this wonderful chat with the
incredible Rami Youssef get it yeah
you can okay
um
yeah in fact I would yeah I totally
recommend it's like a curl up it's a
curl up I'm so happy to meet you man
I've been watching Ronnie uh
in prep oh dude and I'm like why well
because we work in Showbiz and we we're
watching so many great things I know but
I was like why did I wait until you were
doing the podcast to like binge it dude
and I like just straight out the gate
it's so [__] good incredible thank
you man and as someone who made it like
a similar tone yeah yes like this isn't
fake I'm like oh my God like I'm jealous
in the right way like or maybe jealous
isn't the right word I'm like
appreciative yeah of how deliberate it
is how beautiful it is thank you man
like how it's like interesting frames
and the colors like you go to a party
and everything's blue and I'm like yes
that's a meeting yes yes it's a meeting
yes yes you know what I mean like yes
when you're just a fan of TV before you
work in it you're just kind of like oh
they went to a they had a I guess they
went to a party no that was a meeting
that was a DP made a lot of choices yes
and you're acting it's fantastic oh
thank you and the writing is fantastic
just straight up loving it like dude
this is sort of it's not dirty it's not
my favorite thing to say sometimes I'll
watch something guest comes on and then
I'll stop yeah we're not going to stop
that means a lot it's a very specific
comment that means a lot no it is it's a
very like Beyond research yes yes that's
right yeah it is not real I mean well
that's even my point because I'm
embarrassed that it was research because
a lot of people were religious we're
comedians yes or I guess we could say
spiritual I don't I don't know we'll get
into that yeah but we're spiritual when
you when you thanked God on your Golden
Globes what the [__] is going
why aren't we like talking so now we're
finally talking so cool it's great yeah
man and and and the other one more
comment about the show
is when we made crashing like the thing
that was so hard to do was like
a lot of times when you're shooting and
you're riffing a lot yeah you're
building it in the edit yeah and when I
watch crashing I don't think most people
are this way but when I watch it I'm
like we cut to uh across the street wide
because that was the only take where one
of the characters said that line yeah
and Rami has none of that it has this
like feeling of like a bonsai tree like
very deliberate trimmed and constructed
and I envy shows like that big time we
don't riff like we we do but like okay
like we're gonna
I'm I'm gonna make sure we get kind of
um what we need on the page really
deliberately like it's it's kind of like
this it's like we'll rehearse it you
know how it is so it's like we'll
rehearse it something will sound dumb
we'll weed it out but like by the time
the camera rolls there's a version that
I know I want taped and it will get that
twice and then the third one will be
like all right if you want to add
anything now that it's in your mouth but
like I feel like we already got it we
can do that but that's kind of like how
we would do that and we man we barely
would ever get more than a fourth take
or a third take no money we're just
moving fast and we're like you know it's
just like just it's like we just have no
time some Some Day Some episodes we're
shooting four and a half days so
excuse me yeah like I'm like upset yeah
but you know yeah somebody I was just
working on something and somebody told
me this Orson Welles quote and I'm gonna
botch it yeah but it's white wine and
commercials are great have you seen that
no oh you gotta watch it well no no
doing the wine commercials it's drunker
and drunker and drunker it's one of the
great YouTube clips oh my God to watch
it amazing it's really hard to say uh
the words he has to say when he's full
of wine he's like this no it's like a
cliche Flintstones drunk oh my god oh
that's so cool
um he said
uh a lack of restriction is the enemy of
art or something like that right and I'm
like right what you're saying is
confirming that to me yeah because if
you maybe had two weeks to do an episode
maybe you would go into [__] town a
little bit and and and then you have
almost too much to work on what I'm
saying does that sound true or am I
putting words in your mouth no I mean
it's it's a uh it's a reflection in that
I have thought about a lot like I've
even so it's interesting like we
um had to go through a really rigorous
pilot process on on on on making the
show to get it and then I also made Mo
with Mo and we went straight to series
on Mo and I was really happy on that
attack of Romney that yeah no I mean you
have a sweat selling Ramen well made
yeah yeah we were able to get it just
straight to Sears which of course it
really was it was like oh wow we had
done this thing and now we're able to do
that yeah but I was really grateful that
we had that I had so much restriction in
making the Hulu show that then when we
went to go make this like straight to
series thing because I think if I didn't
have that that would have been a
disaster like I actually think it would
have just been way too much and there
were many times in that process of
making Mo where I was like it actually
would have been really helpful to have a
pilot like you know and like you don't
want to admit it right right we want the
security and we want the like you know
give it just give it to us man I've been
doing this right you know like just give
it to me and and and I actually you know
there were a couple times where I was
like this would be a lot easier if we
had a pilot because we could know you
know because right now we're writing
Eight Episodes into the void I don't
know if this person can act I don't know
anything and we're just going I learned
so much for making the Romney pilot
where I was like this Dynamic needs to
now be stretched and this needs to you
know because you you're actually
freaking me out a little bit about how
how nebulous it can be how by the seat
of your pants it can be like in the
pilot of crashing uh George bajel's
character Leaf the guy who has sex yes
that he says we're moving to Tampa
I know because you're like that's all
it's going to be yeah we're like yeah
then you're like whoa they're gone we
need that yeah we need that yeah we need
that guy oh we need that guy and then we
redid it that the then like the season
finale is me and him I think I might be
getting this wrong but it's me and him
looking like we're gonna live together
yeah that's what it is yeah so that's
how important George came to the show
yeah so hear what you're saying that
time you hear about like movies that
shoot over the holidays they have to
take a a month break oh my God and
sometimes it's amazing because you you
get all this time that'd be a dream yeah
yeah it's something I remember this is
over 10 years ago but Melanie was like
there's a reason when they if they're
going to adapt a script or write a pilot
there's a reason they give you four
months or six months yeah and it's
because so much of it is just kind of
like write it finish it yeah stare out
the window go for a drive go for a jog
and you're like wait what are we doing
we can't die you know
and then to your point sometimes you
shoot the pilot and you're like like I I
know you know mo was already great but
you're like we need this Mo Guys Mo
needs to be a big character exactly it's
like Mo and and Dave and a couple of
these guys I don't care for Dave but
yeah yeah yeah
you know what are you gonna do uh but
I'm just kidding which one is my buddy
Ahmad okay with the glasses yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um
but yeah it was like it it was very
informative and I've been thinking a lot
about it lately because I went to see
Avatar and uh the new one right if you
just were like found a dollar theater
they were showing the original Avatar
and it holds up it's really good it well
it was so funny seeing the new Avatar 2
like also uh had such like GoFundMe
energy I was like if we don't go
Hollywood's over like I've never so
obligatory bought a ticket I was like if
this movie doesn't do well yes we're all
screwed like like yeah like movies will
be over movies will be over yeah like
like James Cameron and Avatar it was
yeah if that doesn't kill and it did
right it did but I felt like we all knew
we better go yeah because it really had
this like support the industry it felt
like a fundraiser yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah dude we gotta vote
that's over yeah
I vote and I go to Avatar like I'm not
gonna I believe the way of water yeah
you're gonna be like too cool for school
oh I don't see Avatar oh who gives me
I'll watch it on the plane I care you
get in an IMAX theater right now
democracy depends on you can't make it
absentee that [__] and just buy a ticket
don't show up yes support it by the way
Jim Cameron Jim she's a friend he
doesn't care if you go he doesn't care
if you go buy a ticket and don't go and
the good thing about Avatar is it's a
hang you know what I mean like you could
check emails you could talk to people
like I also went to one of those
theaters where like there's like food so
you can just kind of like oh you're just
so we're ordering food we're in Brooklyn
is this in Brooklyn this was in it's the
this
um I'm gonna promote them the iPic
Theater in Fulton Market in New York but
it's like you're hanging man it's like a
restaurant basically you know you got a
big screen you got three guys that come
in they're bringing you buffalo
cauliflower the whole thing fans yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a very New
York oh we're chilling we're taking
calls we're watching Avatar like it's
not a problem was it good so here's the
thing
I walked away and I was like I know for
a fact no one is allowed to give this
guy a note and I wish someone someone
would able to give him a few look he's a
genius like I look I I love filmmaking I
am like and you know I I'm an aspiring
filmmaker like I want to do these things
so I am this guy is a genius he is
actually a genius yes and you know if if
someone was able to talk to him about a
few things look maybe maybe he does
maybe he has counsel and he already made
a ton of changes
it's probably like we're afraid it
probably so blown away by his genius
because he is genius that they don't say
much and I think a couple things could
have been said and it really would have
been you know something that I think
would have been you know look it's
already an instant classic because I
think what he does visually is just
unbelievable yeah I just think it also
could have been an instant classical on
the story level I haven't seen it yeah I
have a four-year-old yeah I may never
see it you also have though I have yeah
like it's it's like you know what I mean
like did you see the trailer like you
know what I mean yeah
I was at a party this is very Hollywood
but it wasn't even a Hollywood party and
there was a guy who worked on the
effects of that and they told me that
they had like a 5 000 gallon tank of
water yeah that they were like shooting
all of these practical things so it's
hard to go to the guy who has this
god-like and his wafey hair dude and
it's clean vegan living and he's and he
made [__]
goddamn Titanic yeah and it's hard to go
up to that guy and go like maybe what
without having seen it what what is one
of the notes no context just give me one
of your thoughts
a note on Avatar was I mean just there's
a lot of like repetitive story beats
there's just certain things that it's
just it could be shorter you know like
and okay this is my big philosophical
note that you can understand like
without having seen it is that everyone
there fights with like semi-automatic
automatic weapons and rifles
yes oh and that's the whole thing to me
where I'm like why do the navi use
machine guns like wouldn't they have
some way to channel good question
just because I couldn't agree more yeah
it's not explained why they have machine
guns they just have them well I think
the the people who are visiting bring
them in but then the navi like embrace
them and use them and take them and like
shoot up and there's no dialogue of like
should we be using no no and they do it
in the first movie too it's one of the
weirdest things like the first movie my
biggest gripe with it was that you know
what's his name's character Sam uh the
guy the lead dude Worthington yeah
Worthington comes in and there's this
scene it's so funny where Worthington
goes to like this tree it's like this
magical tree and he starts talking to
the tree and being like help me tree
yeah and then the navi are all like
it's not how it works you can't just
talk to the tree and like somehow like
this guy who's like this like Outsider
knows that you actually can talk to the
tree and then like nature helps and I'm
like you tell me these people are stupid
enough that they don't understand that
like their own thing yeah like but no no
Worthington knows that the trees
visiting white savior blue savior blue
savior dude like somehow he understands
their land better than yes they do like
they have the magic but we know how to
use the magic
I'm like wow you have no reflection on
what America did like you don't even
have like any sort of like dude isn't
there an unconscious like sure the
Native Americans had it but we knew how
to we know what to do yeah we really
knew what to do with it yeah yeah
everything's like it's like all it's all
Elvis you know like we knew how to
Market him you know we knew what to do
stealing black music yeah yes I
understand what you're saying it's and
there is
there is like an unconscious arrogance
of like sure we broke a few eggs but
that's a killer Denver omelette dude
no dude did not know it's all Elvis okay
and is there Elvis thing in the way of
the water as well
um are they still after unobtainium I
had a hard time getting over that it was
called um
he struggles with those kinds of things
like naming things and well that's what
I mean there's something that again full
respect Jim full respect
Jim's a friend Jim he's just cruising
YouTube yeah he's crazy and he stumbles
upon this and he's like single tier Jim
yeah he it's he does tend to make movies
that really hold your hand and walk you
through it like you're not gonna miss it
and I think that there's value to that
that's what I mean I think because it's
like you know who like
like you this is a very popular podcast
right like I'm sure you get a ton of
people watching it sure and the people
that you get watching it is still used
underneath this video click over to 12.
no but it's like it's infinitesimally
small compared to like what dude you
know so it's like he obviously is
playing to everybody in a way that like
we never will I think so it's just kind
of like yeah it actually you know what
the thing you can't obtain it needs to
be called unobtanium because there is no
other way that they're gonna remember it
all right so I'm sorry you can sit here
with your nuance and you think it's cool
that when I shot a party scene it was
blue but you know we can go both go [__]
ourselves like because that's that's the
reality is like you actually need to
call it unobtanium well dude if Rami was
My Big Fat Greek my big fat Muslim right
right and I'm not putting down My Big
Fat Greek one actually I'm just saying
you could have been like yes Mom stop
arranging my marriages you know what I
mean and actually in a way when we were
making Mo it's MO is broader like
whenever you get a chance to see it it's
it is
yeah well but Dave's not in it so I
think you should watch it I am telling
you Dave is nowhere near it I love Mo
yeah I know he's so funny yeah and he's
great on your show
I was like this is as good as anything
going you know like some sort of viral
and yeah it's such a throwaway like a
worse show would have made the episode
about whether or not you sent a dick pic
yes but instead you had the restraint
restraint is one of my favorite things
yeah so this is why I'm like you should
have restrained don't call it
unobtainium yes but restraint gets dicks
like me being like right now I know I
know a Golden Glove but it doesn't you
know what I mean like does it it doesn't
blow up I don't want to say a state and
put it down and be a coastal Elite I'm
just saying my mom isn't going to
necessarily jive with it no of course I
mean like if she finds it maybe she will
but like will it get there you know what
I mean and I think that like yeah that
that's that is just when we when we were
making mode we were kind of like all
right this is Netflix and it's gonna be
a little bit broader and I still think
it's incredibly specific in so many ways
but we also were like yeah a couple of
these bits are slapsticky a couple of
these there's things that I would be
less like like I just wouldn't put in
Rami that with Mo and for nothing else
other than that was the choice we were
like no no we're gonna lean in but isn't
Mo Emma we're talking about am I saying
that right yeah
um I don't want to be embarrassed I
didn't come here to be embarrassed he's
got and I would say this to his face
yeah he's got like I want to see him
tumble one of these clowns yes and I
mean that as a comments something
classic comedy classic physical he's
like Laurel and Hardy yeah and by the
way that's like
I don't want to say it's coming back
because I don't think it ever went
anywhere yeah but I do think that like
uh there was some point in which like
being bigger started to become like
something that you know comedy snobs
would find embarrassing and
disrespectful right but then I think
that's what's so funny about like a guy
like Mo and a guy like Sebastian who are
just kind of like no no right this [__]
works and and you know like it's like
there's the comedy that gets to your
head but then there's the comedy where
the guy is tumbling around and he finds
that button in your armpit and he
presses it and you just start dying
laughing yeah and like that kind of
Comedy really makes me laugh I mean it
says like I'm like oh mo and I do
totally different things but I'm just
like man this guy's funny like Sebastian
man this guy's like Sebastian's my
favorite comic right now his specials
are so fantastic and they're so funny
and they're for everybody for everybody
I was so I was shooting something
yesterday and there was the grandmother
of one of the children actors child
actors was going on about how much she
loved Sebastian I was like it's like
look Cosby bad dude right yeah I'm just
saying that market of like yeah this is
for everybody I know that's over yeah
yeah I only apologize for saying Cosby
for 45 minutes yeah yeah yeah it's an
uncomfortable bucket yeah okay so put
that aside but there is a market for
like it's clean
Sebastian will take a premise like
uh paper straws yes and you know I'm
gonna be honest there might be a part of
me that's like I'm not doing paper straw
jokes yes I'm not doing it yes because
it's an observation
my my operation you know the sides of
the thing buzz on the toy if it's
something I could think my dad would say
in a barber shop paper straws you know
you suck on it three times and it's
[__] done like what if I give me a
straw yeah yeah and then Sebastian does
that premise really well guess what yeah
now I'm laughing because it's great and
my dad is also invited to the party yes
now you're selling two tickets
and and and and and that's the thing
it's like I put on Sebastian with my
parents yeah because it's like we want
to watch something and it's so funny
because they're laughing they're dying
and I'm laughing dying right while I was
supposed to like I know if my special's
on like the cool parents will like what
I'm watching and the kids will like it
but like it's not gonna hit in the same
way that like a Sebastian thing does and
that and that's something that I like
really uh I really appreciate it because
the whole point of doing this stuff is
like getting people to connect you know
right and and really like you know
helping people feel less alone and yeah
and do all those things and if you can
laugh with your mom that's incredible do
you as a again we're both raised
religious did you find doing comedy
because y'all will go dirty ish oh yeah
yeah of course not like ugly dirty but
you'll go dirty was that
isn't it weird I feel like if you would
have predicted that what we would have
done when we were 20 I would be doing
what Nate bargets is doing but I'm I'm
up there going like I did a joke last
night on my set on the setlist it's a
jizz on the windshield that was the name
of the bit Yeah like doing jizz on the
list which is an automotive issue that
it is gone unaddressed people aren't
talking about it some of these factories
are putting the windshield wiper fluid
with a different kind of fluid and it's
not healthy it's so fake yeah it's an
industrial Rebellion that has gone
unseen how are the conditions on these
assembly lines that people are [__]
well it almost sounds too fun to make a
car these days like you know I want the
old school like in a factory these guys
are just yes they're seeing electric
cars coming and they're they're they're
just [__] away because they they know
they're human more down yeah they're
saying really actually the Tesla no the
bill was actually about when I see and
at you do in LA people masturbating in
public I really get nervous and I
sometimes the joke is like why and I'm
like my I asked my brain because I was
there was a guy Jay in it on a bus stop
yeah but first of all I put my hand up
to not look yeah like it was too
tempting yeah yeah like there's this
weird like so you kind of wanna look
yeah yeah again not in an arousing way
but just like how the [__] is this
happening and the guy did have a
beautiful it was beautiful
just beautiful deck yeah like everyone
and I kept wanting to look and then I
realized I was very nervous because I
was a red light and I was like why am I
nervous and I'm like my brain
immediately said he's gonna jizz on the
windshield yeah that's the fear and I
was like because I'm gonna get involved
yeah like I'm at an orgy I'm in a car
that's how I mean it's a beautiful
concerns you're connected well what I
like about that joke even though it's
filthy and I didn't mean to sidebarrass
into me open liking it no that it's a
joke about what are you afraid of and
when you ask your brain direct questions
like what do you think is going to
happen yes and it says he's gonna jizz
on the windshield I don't think there's
anything funnier than that certainly
it's funnier to say jizz on the
windshield but it's actually helpful to
go like your brain is stupid this is
where I'm actually at exactly yeah and
it has bad guesses yeah and has bad
guesses for everything yeah like what do
you think your dad would do if this
happened or that let's go back to your
thing so you're dirty but why aren't we
clean that's my question why aren't
um why aren't we doing what Sebastian
does especially seeing as we had like a
little bit more of a pre-conditioning
towards Purity you know what I'm saying
yeah I mean I think it's just like
it's also too it's kind of like stage
Persona versus real life right so I mean
I think it is yeah it's just fun to do
the thing you weren't supposed to do
that's kind of the whole yeah that's
what's fun about this job you know
that's that would be my answer too yeah
yeah and looking back I was listening to
I put on green day today yeah and I was
listening to Longview and I remember the
first time I heard it when I I must have
been 12 or something yeah he says
masturbation he says [__] yeah and I was
just like oh my God and I think that's
what lit the fuse yes secretly for me to
be like I can't wait to be
dirty like that would be a thrill it's
also this thing too I think for me where
it was like you know and I think maybe I
don't know if you had this it sounds
almost insane to say but you grow up in
a a Pious structure and
and I know you know we can get into this
too but it's like in terms of however it
is that you carry it but I had this
thing where I was like all right well if
I'm not I'm a public person I know I
talk I know I communicate well to people
and it felt really clear to me as I was
getting into comedy it's like well
I'm not gonna be an Imam I'm not gonna
be a shake like I'm not going to be that
guy so
I better like double down on what it is
that I'm doing so you know so it's like
I'm not gonna go into comedy and like
kind of be Pious you know what I mean
like it's like no no if you have the
microphone like do the thing that you're
going to do and like be effective at it
so so you know you could have been a
priest yeah you Pete Holmes could have
easily been a priest right you could
have led but we did but we did we did it
so let's not so let's not so if that's
not what we're doing then let's really
not do that like that's the whole point
of this medium yes you know like and I'm
and it almost it what's interesting
about the medium is that it feels like
it's safe to do those things because
we're all agreeing that it's not real
life we're agreeing that we're playing
with something abstract and we're
playing with real emotions and then here
I'm free and here I can do all those
things that I wouldn't do I can say all
those things I wouldn't say I can
reflect in a way that that feels um just
you know more expansive right you know
right that's exactly that's exactly
right so well put that's it's funny part
of me was like should we edit out jizz
on the windshield but then I'm also like
that's the because I was like did I
offend Ron no no I know I didn't know I
mean I know I didn't but you just
articulated why we won't yeah no is
because it's this weird bubble yeah
where the audience for some reason like
a Jester or something goes like I'll
allow it yes yes yeah we're all like
yeah we're agreeing to a suspension of
disbelief every time we get onto a stage
anywhere right you know unless you're
doing one of those comedy shows where
you're like ambushing a restaurant that
didn't know a comedy show was gonna
happen then there's like no agreement
those are the shows I hated the most my
whole like upcoming would be like we're
at a restaurant and it's like half the
people were like what there's comedy
here tonight like they didn't even know
oh no I stopped doing those shows
because I was like it felt sabotage
shows it was sabotage it felt aggressive
it felt it is it felt illegal
um like they didn't consent like you
know we're talking about consent they
did not consent I completely agree very
need consent you need it and yes and
then stuff doesn't hit the same you know
what I mean but
the flip of that
uh there is again there's like guys who
could kind of go and you know like those
situations helped me a lot with stand up
and kind of getting you know an
audience's attention especially an
unwilling one but yeah I think like for
the for the most part what's great about
stand up is we are all there's a
suspension of disbelief we're down to
like jump into this we don't need it to
all be uh not even just
autobiographically true we don't need it
all to be like morally correct and there
are you know we're a very very
uh moral code Society like especially in
America this is a very moral Society you
know might not be Christian it might not
be whatever but whatever you are
whatever it is that you believe you're
really you know you're identified with
it you're very identical tell me what
you mean so I mean if you're if you're
okay so if you're someone who um is an
atheist but you have your things that
you believe in
um that you think are in the opposition
of that right you're gonna be very
stringent as to who can say what and
what can happen right and I think that's
kind of what's going on too with like
online culture is to me it's like for
all of the parody of Christianity or of
religion or whatever we operate from a
very Christian standpoint which is like
hey look what this person tweeted in
2012 they are now no longer ever able to
write or eat at any restaurant right so
it's like that that to me is like like
that's those are what's trials those are
Witch Trials like I don't you know what
I mean like that is that's what that is
like you know what I mean like that's
you know what I'm doing gonna say it is
it's hell it's hell you send them to
help you send them to hell you're doing
it and you sort of love it because if
the evil is over there it's not it's not
you like you're doing it you're you know
so it's like that's what I mean I'm
thrill when people are like did you hear
about I'm like Oh you mean why don't you
just take it's not us it's not me the
Evil's over there and especially when
that on top of it you know they like
because now we're in a situation where
like you know the the country's split
into left and right and the right is
synonymous with religion which is such a
awful like you know marketing situation
but it's like you know then you have the
left acting and whatever acting in
certain ways and they don't believe in
religion but it's like half the time I'm
like I see the way these conversations
go out and it's someone who I know like
hates religion and I just want to be
like you're a Christian
oh you are
whatever the meaning of that word is
because it no longer means anything
right it's like it's just been stripped
of whatever right both no way yeah so
you're uh you hate Christians but you
are one too yeah and it's just like like
we gotta there's there's no there's no
love like there really is no love and
it's and it's incredibly frustrating
well that's how when Joaquin Phoenix did
that acceptance speech where he's like
did you see it where he he did a nice
vegan shout out but he also did the
thing where he was like he basically
pointed out that we love movies about
Redemption yes and forgiveness yes like
they'll make us ball and yes oh you
looked past like dead man walking like
he made mistakes but he you know you
don't throw out the person yeah yeah but
he you know I don't want to spoil the
movie if you haven't seen it's a great
movie but then like in reality we just
can't wait to burn everybody or just
send them to hell yeah I tried for the
longest time but it was working in the
wrong way yeah to do a joke about how as
a as a person who was raised Christian I
was way ahead of the being offended game
you guys are mad at everything now I was
mad at the song OPP like where where
were you during OPP like that was
upsetting to me like Married with
Children was upsetting to me
wait you guys are so late to the game
yeah yeah but I when I would do it in
certain places like I could tell they it
wasn't a joke they were like yes this is
right like we should be judging yeah and
holding people accountable and burning
them the [__] to the ground and I was
like I can't I can't thread the needle
right right but you're a Christian that
is the bet you realize you're a
Christian you guys are Christian you're
a Christian you might not thank the Lord
for your meal oh my God your Christian
but you love that Lord put up a [__]
Christmas tree all year round yeah
it's it's really it's it's and it and it
it drives me nuts like it's really it's
really um you're Christian yeah
you're Christian I don't know what to
tell you why does it drive you nuts
because the hypocrisy obviously and it's
hypocrisy of everybody it's like it's
it's okay so there's there's this huge
issue with uh the way all the religions
are operating right now they're
completely industrialized they're
weaponized they're about putting people
down controlling people making money
that is how religion has manifested in
our lifetimes like I think we're trying
to claw out of that and then I think
there's this response of saying well I
don't want anything to do with that
because I don't want that kind of
Oppression and I don't want that shame
and I don't want all of that I
essentially am saying I want freedom and
I want love and I think that's kind of
what people are trying to say so then to
see the same tactics and the same
systems completely inhabit the the new
thing it feels maddening you know
because uh people are really lost you
know because on one side there's no real
home in So Many religious spaces and and
that is the fault of of you know there's
a
there are big big rotten you know pieces
in the lineage of a lot of these faiths
right now in how people have been
enacting them right and then on the
other end you know you kind of want to
feel like the sense of community but
it's also not there like the line feels
like really really thin and frail and
fragile and so I just think people feel
really alone right now
yeah that's really interesting man a
couple things came to mind it's like do
we know what we want do we know what we
need it's also I forget who said it but
it's like people in the west whatever
whatever you want becomes your God and
yeah like in California specifically
like what's the cliche you come to
California and you become like a love
and lighter yeah you know someone who's
into love and light well yeah we got a
lot of like self-help and we have a lot
of like eating clean and doing yoga and
stuff so that just becomes your God but
it's not like it's not love this is a
big talking point for me it's not
actually love it's just a good feeling
yeah yeah so what becomes our religion
actually or becomes our idea of the
Divine is just the thing that gives us a
good feeling yes right yes but it's not
Mercy don't get me started on Mercy yeah
Mercy is like one of the least appealing
things to the human ego because it means
what we want I've been trying to do a
bit about this yeah we don't want Mercy
we want begrudging forgiveness meaning
like you [__] up I'll forgive you but
I'm going to let you know what it is I'm
forgiving you for and I might even
remind you what it is I'm forgiving you
for like that feels great to the ego
because now there's a Power Balance but
Mercy just dissolves it away you take
the mistake or the or whatever it might
be you dissolve it into a glass of milk
like Ovaltine is gone or yeah or it's
completely used yes or redeemed yes into
a delicious glass of oval tea nobody
wants that no we want
um you know because I I really my deep
feelings like everything is capitalist
everything's capitalist so it's like
even the way we view religion now
totally capitalist I do this I go to
heaven I do this you know it's all like
a bank account right and the same thing
is with forgiveness so it's like
forgiveness is like what you're
essentially saying is like well I'll
forgive you with interest that's right
it's like that's just like like you
gotta like you gotta feel that I'm
forgiving because it can't give me a
good feeling I have an upper hand and
that's all I want I get a little bit
more because I did at Mercy there's no
interest on that it's truly fine hey all
good yes that's it it's you don't get
the extra pad on the back you're
actually just living in a state where
you are truly allowing Mercy right
what's that yeah nobody wants everyone
who wants a leg up you know what's funny
dude
the capitalist thing really works for me
why do we get so worked up if your
Android or iPhone or whatever I think
deep down it's like just on the
windshield what are you really afraid of
with the wrong phone wrong phone I think
you go deep enough down that choice
wrong God yeah wrong life system yeah
yeah and like when you choose your
clothing yeah your car what you eat
where you live all of that is sort of
your capitalistic yeah deity it's your
totem pole of these are are my beliefs
again another bit I'm trying to work on
is that like my God is love and it's
boring as [__] like nobody wants I'm not
talking about like I'll look the other
way on that I mean like dude there's
nothing you could do or have ever done
or could ever do that would change the
way that I am yeah because I'm God yeah
you know what I mean like how can you
change perfect love yeah it's in fact
it's an ego trip to think that you said
[__] or jizz on the windshield
or whatever it might be and now I don't
like you like who the [__] are you that
you can affect God and make him mad at
you like the control room and Jason
Bourne they're like God damn it he
jerked off again like send out more
agents like it's a huge ego chip yeah
but love the the god of love is such a
snooze I say this tongue-in-cheek he's
like a friend that won't talk [__] yeah
yeah yeah you're sitting at the bar and
you're like did you see what Romney did
I mean like he calls himself a Muslim
you know and I like he's even doing this
or this does is he that and and God's
like
won't engage this God sucks like I want
that Old Testament God it would be like
we should Smite him he always wants to
Smite yeah
fighting that's so much more fun yeah
because it feeds our identity if you
suck and I'm not you yeah I get a hit of
goodness and I get to know I'm not you
and identify you and separation and then
if God's over here with me
the the I say this with love because I
spent a lot of my life this way but
there's a lot of egocentrisism it's
egocentric yeah I know what God likes I
know God loves me I know God doesn't
like me yeah it's either Special Love or
it's special hate but either way you
have God by the hair yeah like what you
do is like Shifting The Divine moment to
moment yeah and you just hope you die
when you're on the up yeah that that
that's that's making you really really
really really really special makes you
the center of the universe it's very
torturous I mean everything you're
saying it's like so torturous because
it's like it's such a it's so in line
with our obsessions with like control
and our obsessions with knowing we're so
obsessed with like knowing everything
yes you know and I think what's you like
the future too the future and and what's
inherently you know there with with any
spiritual practices that you're kind of
submitting to the idea that there is an
unseen there is what we don't see and
and everyone has a deal with the Unseen
right even if you don't believe in a
higher power it's like you you that
active choice to say well I'm not going
to engage with blood I don't see that
way is a deal right and and I think that
you're you know there's stuff you don't
see that's those are your fears those
are your anxieties those are your what
might happen well now you're just living
in the the thing you can't see because
it's not in front of you so so we're
always aware that there's stuff we don't
know that's not in front of us and then
we're always in this race to somehow
still know and to somehow you know know
what's going to be in front of us so so
that's that like need to know that need
to control and and that becomes the lens
through how we view everything and
religion certainly can be used you could
criticize religion for that same thing
like the people that look at it okay let
me put it this way
there's a way the way that I look at
spirituality now as a way of
participating with the mystery meaning
you're not going to get like a printout
of exactly what's going on so it's a way
of engaging with the unknown and
humility and surrender is a huge part of
that going like I don't know yes I
believe there is a knowing yeah a large
knowing that I can
merge with and be with but that doesn't
necessarily mean that I'll be able to be
like let me tell you how everything
works sure because that that would be
Pete I'm talking there's another thing
there's another part of me that can
merge with that knowing yeah but that's
kind of a private experience that's what
prayer is or contemplation or meditation
or whatever it might be
um but you could say that one of the
things that religious people get
criticized for and I would say fairly is
what you're saying as well because if
it's if you use your faith as a
I'll tell you the story
as a way to end the conversation going
like God said it I believe it that does
it yeah that's also a type of arrogance
and a type of knowing that stops the
participation with the mystery and stops
that sort of visceral engagement right
now yeah I say this all the time we're
on a planet right now yeah we are both
aware right now you're in my awareness
and I'm in your awareness that's [__]
nobody understands that yeah it's
[__] nuts yeah that something is
happening yeah we have the impression
that something is happening and we we've
done a pretty good job analyzing what's
happening yeah but we don't have it all
figured out and the story I was going to
tell you was I'm walking out of a movie
it was a Superman movie at Union Square
walking out and the little boy said to
the dad his daddy goes how'd they make
that man fly yeah and the dad just goes
computers
and I'm like that's what so many of us
do computers just means something I
don't understand is doing something I
don't know what yeah but like if you
stop at computers either you say it was
God and you use it to stop yeah you say
it was nothing yeah and you use it to
stop both of those are sort of in my
view faulted like you're it's supposed
to be engaged with
as often as you can yes in every moment
that you can yeah in fact that vigilance
is what all of the great teachers seem
to agree on that yes there's a premium
on being present yes and I like the word
Vigilant Jesus actually Likens God to a
burglar who's going to break into your
house you should wait for God like a
house have you ever been awake at night
thinking someone's breaking into your
house how are you yeah
um and that was and they talk about uh
be as careful as among Crossing ice like
a frozen River like that's how wow you
can move like stop taking everything for
granted I'm going to bed yes I wake up
and eat breakfast that's what I'm trying
to say to you right now this could be it
yes this could be it yes so what do we
know right now yeah so I I just unloaded
a lot on you forgive me no like using
religion as a way to stop the
conversation I feel like it seems like
we're in agreement let's not do that
either or yeah using it as a book of
answers of course I mean it's like
everyone you know in their own way and
this is kind of what we're talking about
earlier this is a behavior of human
beings you know and I think that like
the conversation maybe is a little
shifted towards you know oh this is what
religious people do because I think that
um religion the the unique thing about
religion
is that it leverages the Unseen to
control people and I think that the just
gonna say that that's great that's what
it does it's like like the the industry
of religion leverages the Unseen to
control people that's the negative
because you can sell people a lot by
going you don't know what this is you
don't know what's going to happen and
I'm gonna throw in this you don't know
what happens after you die right that's
a great way to start a time share
presentation and and then and then the
flip with what we have with what is like
this new culture is leveraging the scene
to control people so it's like well I
saw him do that look at what this person
did and all you're looking at is one
tiny thing and then or whatever it is or
it could be a huge thing and and you
know whatever it is we're only looking
at what we can see and then controlling
with that and so they're really both
difficult positions to be in like and
and that's why I say it it seems to me
that this is just the behavior of people
like I think it's like how do we how do
we separate you know there are a lot of
amazing deep wisdom traditions on this
Earth and it is an arrogance to think
that they've only been here because we
haven't been able to update them you
know like like our thinking is just like
everything is just like well we only use
mail because you know we didn't have
Wi-Fi and now there's no mail like
that's how we look at all these
Traditions that's right and and and and
I think that that is really arrogant
because I think it it you know because
even the Wi-Fi mail thing is arrogant
because it you know I I constantly walk
around like that Monk on Ice thinking
what happens when there's just a few
little tweaks and like electricity's
[__] and internet's [__] you know all
these things are so fragile right
they're so fragile like we're just like
like like it is it is insane how quickly
we'll need to like mail a [__] letter
or like or like there'll be like some
point you know where we're just like the
shit's not working you know like like
just not having Wi-Fi in your house
no yeah but it's like it's suddenly
mailing a letter
like yo the mailman will be just this
[__] hero you know Kevin you know
it's like the post yeah he's back this
guy is just like nails back baby you
know like but like yes all these things
you know where we get so egotistical
about it we get so egotistical about it
dude and you're right but it's magic
it's it's like uh worshiping your own
strains yes with no appreciation for the
fact that all of that strength is
floating in Spanish there's just there's
clear lineage you know things come like
in a certain way there's a chain of
human beings and I think the more we
look back and and you know because look
we can look back and see horrendous
things you know you look back into the
past and you see just dark [__] and then
you say okay well I'm glad we got past
that and like you know as people but you
know it's it's so funny even as I say
that I question it because I was about
to say you look back and you see slavery
and you look now and it's not here and
it's like well slavery that we learned
about in textbooks thankfully has been
you know changed in America and there is
so much slavery happening right now
there are more slaves than there have
ever been like just to make the [__]
that we consume on 24 7 that fills every
shelf there the way we look at what's
happening in so many countries around
the world you know so these things are
still happening so it's actually really
hard to even say that we've like
eradicated you know a lot of things but
the the the thing I'm I I'm kind of
trying to Anchor this in is that like to
me it's people I think you know to just
say religion is [__] or to just say
Liberals are [__] or to just say this
thing is [__] it no it all of the
these points of view and all these paths
clearly all have legitimacy and they
need to be treated with the respect of
having legitimacy and then understand
that man the wrong people in any of
these would be really you know are
devastating you know they're they can do
devastating things to others there's a
way to corrupt this anything for sure
anything yeah so many things are coming
up it's interesting when I look at
organized religion I I'm one of those
that like I'm not even really trying to
[__] with that yeah I'm not even trying
to save it it's overwhelming right I'm
also an introvert so what I'll say about
my spirituality is I like how private it
is meaning like it does just come down
to like when I close my eyes I try and
get in touch this is Rupert Spira I'll
say it anytime I can
your experience is known like you see
things but there's a part of you that
knows it yeah right so you hear things
but there's a part of you that knows
that so to me spirituality is is
interested in that knowing presence yes
I've said this a million times but I'll
say it every time it comes up because
that's so important that very few people
ever stop to go what is it that's aware
of my experience yes like where does it
all go to where it's seen yes he Likens
it to a movie screen he's like you watch
a movie you get all caught up in the
drama you forget that there's a screen
our awareness is the screen you could
also say it's the piece of paper that
everything is written on the one that I
trip out on is like even if a sound is
far away like you might hear a car or
you might hear my voice very close it
doesn't matter they're both as close as
they can possibly be to you because
they're inside of you they are you like
there's the there's the Sensation that
one's dimmer and brighter but they're
you and everything
is touching is knowing seeing is knowing
like does that oh yes yeah so when I
close my eyes going back to the private
part of it and I try to just go like
what is that what is the experience of
that knowing without any
input if I can just look at a blank
screen and when I get there I go like
all right what the mystics the sages and
the prophets were saying was right on
when I look at what people are doing
with that experience I get a little
shady I have a joke I go I believe in
God but I hate when other people believe
in God because I never know which one it
is yeah yeah there's so many it could be
a terrible one yeah as father Greg Boyle
says wrong God like if your God is he's
like wrong wrong one it's like if it's
that or whatever so anyway what do you
what do you make of the do you enjoy the
private relationship you have is that
cleaner or pure because you don't have
to look at the capitalism of it or the
organization of it or the history of it
you can just it's all about the private
yep that's that's what it is like that's
when you're saying that I'm like um yes
that is that is all that it's about and
that's what is so frustrating about
religious culture is that everything is
like I think the the goal of all these
things is to create Community where you
can find others where you can kind of
share a space where you're aligned
um but also knowing that it is a private
Journey like we're all we're a
collection of people interested in a
private Journey interested in a private
journey and and and that's where the
community comes in and that's what's
interesting and that collection can help
govern it can help do a lot of things in
in idyllic worlds but like we know it's
going to malfunction because we're human
but the goal really and I think it is is
to understand that you know I grew up
with um
and they'd say it in Arabic but my whole
family all the time all the time at the
end of any sentence at the end of
whatever it would just be a real quick
only God knows you know just really only
God Only God knows only God knows
you know like that's I mean only God
knows that's that's
you know what what do we know yeah you
know like and and and and
sitting in that in like a real way that
that's a great way to access Mercy
because you really are just like
like and you know you look at modern
things in America where you're just kind
of like you brought them up a guy like
Cosby it's like for a long time only God
knew and and a few you know people who
are really hurt yeah and the rest of the
world was convinced well wow here's this
like guy who's who's like an Arbiter of
justice and this and that and this icon
and like you know the impact of who he
was cannot be understated I mean it's
just like whoa It's like this guy's was
was was was he shifted culture in
massive ways and was also doing so many
things that were the opposite of what he
said he was doing and whatever he's
shifting right you know but you're using
I love the way you're using you're
saying look The Virtuous can also be
yeah I don't want to say Wicked but
we'll just say Wicked but the wicked
might be virtuous like the the breaking
down so the work of um Byron Katie is
really meaningful to me and she she has
something called the work where you say
like let's say I say uh rami's greedy
just something negative yeah and you
just you just question it you go is that
true yeah and you go yeah it's [__]
true I lent him a thousand dollars and
he never paid yeah yeah yeah can you be
sure that it's true that's the second
question yeah it's so I have the chills
just think about it no one does that can
you be sure that it's true very few of
us do it and you just go like
I don't know man yeah there's a great
Freedom realizing you don't have to be
the judge you don't have to go around
judging everything like you [__] know
I'm talking about you know what I mean
like totally what do I know is going on
in your life Katie and I uh no I'm sorry
Kat was just here sorry I keep confusing
you two people were here and I confused
them not you Kat and I we're talking
about when someone doesn't reply to a
text and you'll be like what a piece of
[__] and you're like you've never opened
a text and gone like I need to reply to
that and then you close it yeah forget
about it yeah but that times a hundred
billion is all of the different things
that could be going on yeah so that
that's fine that's a nice thought
experiment it's like a graduation speech
I could give no no not at a non Ivy
League school but the the conclusion is
so put the bags down yeah that's Freedom
yeah when you realize you can't judge
yeah accurately then you stop judging
and then you know what you are you're
smiling Saint yeah that's what the
saints were doing they weren't
and I think you know the the thing
that'll always because I I've I've
really thought about this a lot because
it's like I don't want to judge right
and I want to be like in that that kind
of you know saintly thing and I'm I'm
very active working because obviously
part of what we do is like judge we've
sharpened our swords pretty sharp you
know and it's also like to do comedy
right yeah that's what we do that's what
we do people bring us topics and we go
yeah yeah yeah but the thing you know
actually like I had this big kind of
breakthrough with um with kovid because
it was kind of this this it it did
something uh how I viewed a lot of these
things uh and it became so simple it was
kind of like okay uh a friend has covid
because this was the first time it
really felt like this friends would be
sick you'd still hang out with them you
don't give a [__] you know before kovid
someone's sneezing oh what are you sick
I'm not gonna stay away from you I don't
give a [__] I was just talking about
that feel Invincible you might not shake
their hand somebody Maybe
I think I was too because if you were
Howie Mandel doing this we were like
what is this guy how are you it felt
weird now we're all like yeah you know
we all have rules yeah but I remember it
really hit me and I was like oh wow like
okay my friend has kovid he's still my
friend I love him but I can't be in the
same room with him right now because he
has covid I gotta wait my friend isn't
covet right my friend is not the
coronavirus my friend has the
coronavirus my friend is amazing he
currently has the coronavirus in two
weeks I can see him okay my friend is
greedy yeah is my friend greedy or does
he have that does he have greedy on him
like is he Afflicted with greed right
right so so it's like you know what I
mean like like that started to be like I
was like oh whoa no my friend currently
has greed
he's not greedy he's good
if I were to sit and think about his
life I could and only God knows but
let's just say because I actually do
need to make some judgment calls in
order to protect myself you know there's
this whole I remember there's this
podcast Listen to I cannot remember what
it was but there's this podcast I
listened to that was like you know our
brains need to know this is a couch and
not a bomb so that we can sit on it
right so on some level we are making
judgment calls that we have to make in
order to put ourselves in positions to
feel healthy and feel happy and feel all
the things we want to feel so I I can
make a level of saying my friend there's
something going on with greed I'm not
going to try and connect all the dots
but maybe I've seen enough to say
there's something going on with greed
but is he I'll never say that maybe he
has greed so what does that mean well
maybe that means I'm not gonna bring him
to my house because maybe he'll look at
my [__] in some way right that feels
weird right and that means I just gotta
meet with him if we're gonna hang out we
hang out outside we hang out at a coffee
shop you know so there's certain people
that you're like oh they have something
going on right that might need to change
like how I interact with them in order
for us to both access the most loving
the most merciful the most amazing part
so that other stuff doesn't get in the
way right and that's how I've really
viewed because I had all these
friendships that were kind of
complicated where I was like man like
why do I feel this why I don't feel that
but I know I love him and it just
started to become clear I was like he's
good
we are all good
and then maybe it's like oh right now he
has jealousy right now he has anger and
I can kind of only God knows but I can
kind of suppose why those things happen
so now that I know that what are the
rules for how I'm going to interact so
that I'm not bitter and so that I'm not
walking around hurt and so that I can
appreciate like the love that I do have
you're separating the person from the
the symptom yeah my mind I frame it is a
spiritual illness you know there's
something going on like in the Unseen
that they're what gave it to him it
probably wasn't just him he didn't want
it going out licking that's such a good
point it's so important yeah I don't
think anyone wants to be this one no I
don't think no one wants to be angry I
would say he's scared like to me it's
always it always comes down to some
feeling of unsafety yes or you know you
just don't feel
okay in your body you don't feel okay in
the world you you're you know how
complicated it can get in here yeah and
it comes out as like if I had more money
yeah I could finally protect myself yeah
or if I was big and scary I could keep
all that other people away from me I
mean it's it's a cliche you see it in
movies it's like the scary guy that just
needs love sorry the story is so boring
guys but like it turns out I didn't make
this up but everything is either love or
asking for it it's like the scary guy is
asking for love and I know we think that
just means being nice yeah [__] that
[__] A lot of people are turned off by
just phony nice just kind of like I
wanna Werther's original that's not love
yeah what Fred Rogers was doing that's
more like love it's about space can you
give them space maybe the most loving
thing I can do to you if you if you had
anger was to let you be angry yes you
know what I mean not not just being like
let's get a cupcake yes where did I
learn that a [__] commercial
and that's so important what you're
saying too because it's like even in the
framing that I was kind of providing
it's not like it's not like if I know
you're angry I can't be around you it's
more like I think the the the intention
I'm having is like if I know your anger
is so overriding that there's nothing
like that I can do then maybe I'm gonna
treat you in a different way but also
it's like let's create the space for
people to just be angry and to do what
they need to do just so you don't feel
weird there's a lot of times in my life
where I go this is gone I always quote
this line from Lord of the Rings I go
this is beyond my skill to heal yeah
I uh I can't I could give you a lot of
space but right now this is toxic why do
I have the capacity it's just uh it's
like the air rating there's just a
little too much smoke here yeah let's
let you ride this out and by the way it
might be just because I'm busy that day
yeah like it might just be actually I
could totally handle like how much of a
dumpster fire you are just on Saturday
like you know what I mean like I just
can't do this [__] this like this
Tuesday it's really busy but actually
like all these [__] Shenanigans yeah
no problem let's just do it not now not
today like I could do this on Saturday
yeah and if you can't wait till Saturday
and you think now I'm the devil because
I made you wait four days to lose your
mind in front of me right then well now
that's on you that's not on me well you
know Byron Katie would also say on that
like so let's say you're going through
anger and I say I can hang out with you
Saturday and it's Wednesday and you call
me a [__] piece of [__] I hate you
you're not a real friend you can do that
on on that belief Rami is mad at me yeah
is that true yeah well yeah he just
yelled at me called me a piece of [__]
yeah and you know that it's true and I'm
like like you've never been mad so mad
at yourself so mad at the world so
matted you do nothing I can't
at Delta the airline yeah so I'm gonna
yell I don't do this but I'm gonna yell
at the person
they're not mad at the person at the
desk but in the same way Rami is mad
the the quick one would be Rami just had
a death in the family yeah but why do we
need that like
it's what I say like uh in the movie
Green Book like yeah we can go on a road
trip with anybody you can go on a road
trip with your enemy and realize we're
all the same yeah we don't have time for
five million road trips so can we just
[__] jump to the conclusion yeah and
act from the Assumption of love and and
just I mean what what do you have to
lose yes yeah no it it really is like
that
um is is to me as you're saying it it
connects with what we're talking about
earlier just like that desire to need to
know yeah you gotta know so it's like
this person yelled at me all right I
gotta categorize it as they're angry at
me it's like hold on for one sec right
you know and explain to me when you're
talking about the niceness thing I just
was reading um you know Gabor mate he he
has this uh new book he's really just
amazing uh amazing author oh he he's
like you'll you'll love him but he's
laying out some studies around people
who are like that Werther is chronically
nice
um
having really serious illnesses people
Pleasers yeah having really serious
illnesses because they're holding things
in they're getting cancer they're
getting all these things and a lot of
the healthcare professionals can tell by
someone's disposition in the room if
they have the terminal illness or not
like that that like they had a crazy
radar of being able to know oh that like
plastered on like whatever whatever
that's going on with this person I think
they're actually sick but if the person
is a little more like expressive and
whatever they're like oh it's probably
something else like this person doesn't
seem right like they have you know like
it it wild like it's like emotionally
you want to be more like a river than a
like a pond and that's with getting your
blood moving that's with getting your
digestion moving that's with all that
stuff like literally in the Physical
Realm but also emotionally that's one of
the great things about having a partner
like Val and having the friends that I
have sometimes it's just so beautiful
I'll say to Val like I'm just being mad
and then say what I'm mad about yes
because to this guy I haven't read his
book but like if you let what does a
pawn do it turns green and stuff
professors are smelling like [__] yeah
keep it running yes that's why you know
I'm with you I I try to forgive meaning
I have very specific thoughts about
forgiveness I don't try to forgive I try
to dissolve what I think is an affront
in God's love meaning I can't do it I
try to surrender the a front or whatever
it is into God's love because I know I
know me get the [__] out of here Pete's
not gonna forgive [__] Pete's gonna be
like yeah he'll forgive him and then
like later down the line he'll owe me
yeah
he's always gonna look I'm not proud of
that yeah that's the way the ego is it's
like what can I get out so much we're
all doing it yeah [__] sweet old
grannies newborn babies are doing it
they're figuring out ways to like get
their needs meta meaning it's not evil
no no but I do not go to my ego for
forgiveness Mercy or love or
understanding I'm like we got to get
Pete to the side yeah and then and
that's that's my work as I go I was
thinking about somebody that I was just
like really hard on and I was like what
am I doing I'm like I can't
intellectualize I actually think it's
really cheap to intellectualize like
maybe they're having a bad day [__] that
[__] just give it to the love that deep
down I really am yeah meaning it's not
even an abstract thing I mean it's that
it's what as I always say it's what's
looking at our eyes right now Mercy is
looking at your eyes right now it's in
you find it and kick that [__] into the
fires of Mount Doom that's the only
chance you have yeah because if you go
like oh forgive you Dad yeah everyone
was doing their best like [__] off
that's what therapy is telling me I need
something stronger I do I literally need
someone to go like no the force that
created the universe is somewhere in you
yeah find it drag that dead
us to it yeah and roll it in like the
mob yeah roll it in and walk away that's
your only chance and you won't even
really be there to do it because Pete
won't do it yeah if any of that made
sense no we I mean to me it sounds like
submitting to God yeah exactly that is
what that's funny the further I go the
more I come back to life it's like going
like you got to trust God
you were a step away from saying in a
way that I would have like totally
agreed with Jesus Christ Lord and Savior
like you were like a step away from
saying that like that's essentially like
it but I think what's what is and it's
and what's so cute
what's so clear about this all to me too
though is like you even saying that step
further away and then come back to it
there is what's missing in so much
Community Building
um is that Journey you need to question
you need to all that and then come back
to it you need to like actually live
raising my hand please we're coming back
when we come back we're going to talk
about that journey and how important it
is to walk away from it and return to it
yes it's what Richard Ward calls yes no
yes it's ordered disorder reorder it's
one of my favorite topics but I want to
hear you talk about it for facts oh I
don't know anything about it
yeah yeah your specific Journey when
you're talking about like leaving the
village going on the journey and coming
back couldn't be more interested we just
have I don't even know if we have a
mid-roll on this episode but if we do
it's happening right now
this episode guys is brought To Us by
our friends at next Evo next Evo is made
the best and most quickly absorbed CBD
that I have ever had and not only that
they blend it with things like
adaptogens that help your body cope with
stress so you are attacking stress at
two places at two levels and it is
absolutely absolutely become a must-have
for me this is one of those ones where I
use my own promo code and Order tons and
tons of their stress gummies the new
year is a great time to try this if
you've never tried it it's an
opportunity to achieve your full
potential but you can't do that if
you're stressed so get ahead of stress
this year by experiencing the full
potential of CBD with next Evo Naturals
Nevo next Evo Naturals is the most
clinically studied CBD brand and their
smart sorb technology can help get you a
better start to the year with products
like my favorite stress CBD complex the
whole thing so many people tell me
because they know I'm into CBD they go I
don't feel it I don't know how much to
take I don't know what's going on
there's a lot of confusion the smart
sword technology is basically they
figured out how to get it into it's over
30 times better absorption and that's in
the first 30 minutes so you can get your
dose just right and you can know how
you're going to feel very very quickly
don't just use any CBD brand most CBD
products on the market only have two to
ten percent absorption so that's at
least 90 percent actually wasted next
Evo is different it delivers four times
better overall CBD absorption and has
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and it's mashed mashed up with like a
mashup ashwagandha which I am obsessed
with anyway so this is a great way to
get the adaptogen ashwagandha into
clinically proven to reduce stress by up
to 70 and improve concentration by 50 so
this isn't like a wind down thing this
isn't a lemon dominate stress which is
in the way of you either enjoying your
day or getting your work done I take it
before I do stand up I take it before I
write I take it before I do this podcast
so make CBD a part of reaching your full
potential with next Evo Naturals go to
nextevo.com podcast and use promo code
weird to get 20 off your first order of
40 bucks or more that's 20 off 40 or
more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast with
code weird we're also brought To Us by a
couple new Pete's picks which I'm very
excited about one of them is rocket
money rocket money formerly known as
true bill is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place when I first heard about this I
was like what a brilliant idea over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
that they have totally forgot about and
I'm totally guilty of this like that
streaming service you bought just to
watch one show on or that free trial
that you never even used well how do we
find them for me they were lost in the
shuffle until I used rocket money rocket
money will quickly and easily identify
your subscriptions for you so you can
stop paying for the ones you do not want
and do not use rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button simply find the
subscription you don't want and press
cancel rocket money will cancel it for
you no more long hold times with
customer service or tedious emailing
back and forth where they're trying to
talk you into staying with them it's all
done with rocket money over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year 720 a year it couldn't be easier I
personally had way more I'm not even
comfortable telling you how many
subscriptions I had it was way too many
and with a click of a button rocket
money canceled them all and saved me a
ton of bread so stop throwing your money
away cancel and wanted to descriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com weird that's
rocketmoney.com weird one more time
rocketmoney.com weird last but not least
just in time for the most rainy season
that California has seen in years I am
so happy to have discovered vessi shoes
these shoes are a game changer what are
not only do they look amazing but what
is the vessey cloudburst and why is it
the best shoe to have for me personally
as it's raining like crazy here in
California or just anywhere in Winter
well they have all the features of a
rubber winter boot built into a sneaker
it's truly incredible 100
waterproof not water resistant
waterproof that means waterproof and
warm yet lighter and more comfortable
than boots they just look like cool
sneakers honestly they're like fashion
forward I looked at them I was like the
way that this the diamond text Diamond
text the dimetex uh coating looks I was
like this is a cool pattern that like a
hip designer would use but they're
completely waterproof warm they have a
lugged rubber outsole that gives you
extra grip and wet conditions which I've
been benefiting from because I've been
having to go outside into the yard to
prevent flooding added lining inside for
an extra warmth in the cold and they
slip on and off it's quick and easy to
get outside no more lacing up crazy
boots made from diamondtex like I said a
super soft knit material that keeps your
feet warm in the cold but cool in the
warmer months it doesn't feel like it
should be waterproof but it is and
they're super comfortable and as I
mentioned they look super cool so Bessie
are my go-to shoes by my door they keep
me dry they keep me warm which is so
important in California right now if
you're following the news check them out
in the link vesi.com weird that's
v-e-s-s-i.com weird for a pair of your
vessi shoes and check them out show your
support of the show they have lots of
styles to choose from I'm looking for
some sort of promo code I'm not seeing
it oh it's just slash weird yeah
vessi.com weird support the show keep
your feet dry look cool keep them warm
keep them cool in the summer they're
incredible bestie.com weird alright
everybody let's get back into Rami
Youssef
okay and we're back
um just tell me what you meant I really
I get so excited about this stuff yeah
yeah me too and I just don't want to
talk too much because I'm so excited to
be talking with you and I think you're
brilliant and I'm excited but what did
you mean before we get to my Richard
word yes no yes but like that that going
away from it what did that mean to you I
grew up with an understanding of
Islam that I grew up in was that our
faith asks us to question everything
including the faith itself and that is
what helps strengthen your experience as
someone who is living it and embodying
it I grew up with that I grew up with
that and like being at the Bedrock of
question everything read you have yeah
go ask questions figure that out what a
great service by the way yeah to an
understanding of the infinite mystery
the breadth of the universe the love
that hung the Stars I believe is what
Dante called it but like this powerful
thing but we're so fragile with them
yeah but don't read
don't read Richard Dawkins yeah or it's
all going to go away so you're telling
me well one of the one of the most kind
of there's
um uh really prominent Imam gazali
really prominent in Islam uh and part of
his story as just one of the greatest
thinkers of our tradition is he kind of
has this crisis and says wait I need to
know all of the other faiths to realize
am I really in the right place am I
really doing that I think any anything
yeah and he and he takes that time and
he does it and this is you know one of
the most you know revered quoted
embodied figures in our tradition wow
and so this is like Billy Graham to
bring it back to the white folks but
like 100 JK but to bring it to like yeah
Christianity yeah Billy Graham goes I'm
gonna read the Quran but I would call
[__] on that more than that yeah I'm
gonna like
look at it I'm going to see what's there
I'm going to read yeah uh the
bhagavad-gita or whatever it might be
yes and that so there's a big symbol of
Islam does this yeah yeah just that
questioning and that understanding and
it's like you have to know and it's also
too with Islam the the thing to keep in
mind as well is that there's a belief
that you know all of the books are books
from you know prophets and Messengers
and so it's like it you know it's this
you know way of looking at the world of
saying oh we're all it is all connected
you know there is that lineage that
that's how you know and of course you
know Islam's like and we're the final
best version but yeah that's its own
thing but but to me like the the thing
that I and and it's really there's so
many schools it was the latest update
though it was like I'm not trying to be
funny no no Judaism Christianity has a
little bit of a willwer yeah the update
yeah yeah yeah and you don't always read
all the terms and conditions yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then Islam comes
and Muhammad said Jesus was a prophet
Moses and Moses that's why it's the big
three it's the monotheistic big three
yes but yes I could see their
intertwined but in Islam would they mind
if you wanted to [__] with Hinduism or
Buddhism it sounds like in your branch
read about it I mean like look I think
that there is you know of course there's
going to be this understanding of like
you should be Muslim but
duh like I mean they're not you know
they're not gonna not say that they're
not gonna I'm not gonna not say you're
not gonna be like hey go try the other
stuff and maybe you end up there like
it's not that it's not but it is it is
kind of this idea of like you know it's
almost like um
it's like a really confident money-back
guarantee you know it's like it's really
like it's just like it's like we will
we'll oh we'll give your money back 100
100 guarantee go ahead try out the other
ones you're gonna come back or we'll
give you money back
I guarantee it Islam yeah it's really
like originally yeah it is it is it is
so confident yes in like you know in
that and so
you know that's the tradition that's her
but okay I mean I'm gonna call it that's
as good as it gets when it comes to a
religion's perspective sure on looking
at other faces because you know you kind
of have to be like you'll you'll be back
of course you'll be back of course
otherwise why would you be there yes
exactly yeah so when you you're raised
in it yeah
um and then what was the inciting
incident for like I'm gonna look at
other things or was it just throughout
you were always looking at other things
no I definitely like had a Fascination
especially in high school you know I
remember I was like
it's high school and a little shortly
after high school one time I was working
at the Apple Store and and this guy was
like who I worked with was like uh you
know you're only Muslim because you grew
up in it you know that right and then
you just like walked away like it was
like it was like it was like it like hit
me in my car yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll
never forget I think it was 32 when I
figured that out that somebody was like
it was Pete Rollins he's like what you
your faith is when you were born yeah
which is a real noodle Baker what if you
were born before
Muhammad yeah yeah you were born before
Jesus yeah you would have or where you
were born and to whom you were born yeah
and there's nothing wrong with that you
just kind of have to go like
I'm with you right I would have
worshiped raw right if I was born in
Egypt right let's concede the point
there's no reason to go but I did I
would be like no Jesus would have
whispered to me on the Wind no matter
what like I would have found you which
is just kind of like another way of
saying no my mom and dad will find me if
I'm lost in the woods yeah it's as close
to you as your parents like what what
you were raised yeah I was really raised
too with like you know we respect the
people of the book and I think that that
is you know it would be talking about
Christians would be talking about Jews
you know like this is you know in our
tradition in our faith to say we respect
people in the book and you know they're
all on the path to God as well like this
was there right and I think you could
extend that you know to to anyone who is
like truly seeking that you know higher
power love like like looking at the
Unseen in a certain way obviously
there's all these and it's because even
within the faith there is uh massive
debates that that have gone on
throughout the course of the history
which is hey what we're reading in the
Quran did this happen didactically or
are these Parables and are these just
you know ideas that are supposed to be
symbols for what we're supposed to be
doing and there are people on both sides
and they're both legitimate positions to
hold you know you can say no this is
historically exactly what happened and
there's a bunch of people who are saying
yes that's it and you say people this is
these are you know symbols and these are
things that are you know here to teach
us and it is our job to personalize all
of this so that it all fits into what
we're doing so so there's all these
different ways of thinking about it
um so so I I am definitely you know
someone who's like yeah whoever is just
seeking like I'm attracted to Seekers
that's like what I'm Into You know if I
think about what you've made and like
what what we do on our show it's like
you know you're seeking like that's
what's interesting that's what's
interesting about this conversation so
anyone who who's on that it's it's
always really yeah that that's what
we're I love that and I think what you
were talking about earlier
is how frustrating it can be when the
seeking is turned off so there are
people who are part of the religion and
like it like it ends there it's almost
like we're just gonna hone in on these
stories and these details without
curiosity without seeking or just taking
it and downloading it and that's it and
then it's like a very robotic existence
right right it's not a river anymore
it's a pond it's a pond yeah and so that
that
thing you know and I'm curious you know
to to to to what you're about to tell me
because I I feel like I'm gonna be
really excited by it it's like it's just
like that that Circle we're talking
about it's like that that to me is that
never turning off that seeking never
turning off that Curiosity that that was
something that was very important for me
and and so when that guy had said that
to me like oh you're only this because
you were born in it or whatever uh it
was Steve Jobs it was Stephen Jobs uh he
walked in and as he often did as he
often did checking in every Apple Store
and you know how it is you know when
you're dealing with people that I mean
you know Jim it's another gym yeah this
is like Legends in their fields walking
up to you and you're just trying your
best and of all the things he could say
you know to the one Muslim employee
[Laughter]
it was also yeah I remember it I was
already there but it was like in
incredible like fuel that fueled even
more reading for me and more experiences
for me and made me realize that's a gift
it's a gift well that's what always
happens is the the hero resists the call
and yeah like you you get it and one of
my favorite ones is is there's a there's
a wolf
and he gets separated from his pack and
he's raised by sheep so some sheep find
this little baby one yeah yeah and the
uh wolf gets raised by the sheep and
eventually uh they give him some uh wool
to wear it looks like a little sheep but
it's a wolf it lives with them into
adulthood and he's eating grass and all
this stuff and then one day a wolf sees
the wolf living with the sheep and he
goes up to him he grabs him and he goes
you're a wolf and of course he's like
what the [__] are you talking about I'm
a sheep and then he gets meat and he
Force feeds it to the the wolf sheep
that had only been eating grass and he
chokes on it and I think that's super
important is the call to awaken to your
true identity I would I would say this
is Way Beyond culture this is this is a
metaphor for what God is doing to us
saying like wake up you're not this
you're something else and we choke on it
and that's a super important part of the
story you don't just eat the meat and go
like yeah guess I'm a wolf yeah you hate
it yeah feels like death yeah in fact
from what I've experienced and from what
I've studied that's how you know it's
happening is you go this is The Dark
Knight of the Soul he goes like this is
absolute death I'll never come back from
this you're very close to realizing your
wolf and then you'll go back and be in
your wolf pack you know what I'm saying
so and you go kill all those sheep and
you of course you go and kill yourself
fake dad and your fake brother and your
old girlfriend everything's Star Wars
that we were having sex by the way
um but what I'm saying is when people
would say that to me like you're only
Christian because you were raised that
way or the Bible contradicts itself or
whatever there's take your pick there's
a million things you could say to
dismiss it all you really think of
talking snake talk to a naked woman all
that sort of stuff uh you hate it yeah
and then it ends up being the journey
that you have to go on mine was my
divorce that's crashing is a hero's
journey and my life is a hero's journey
that doesn't mean I'm special
everybody's typically on something
resembling a hero's journey and my
getting kicked out of the village was my
wife having an affair and leaving me
then it ends up being the most essential
thing but I Lose My Faith and what I was
going to say was the yes no yes is you
say yes when you're a child then you say
no at a certain point usually in some
point of like discomfort or doubt or for
a lot of people it's College like that's
a cliche like you take your philosophy
course yeah this is actually dumb and
you go back go back and tell your
parents like it's actually not the way
that it is and that's great really
that's a Mitzvah that's like a joyful
thing because that no then that goes
back to the yes often it doesn't yeah
culture doesn't really celebrate that
but if it goes back into the yes the
second yes is the meaningful yes yeah
the first yes was just because a bunch
of animals told you what you were the
second yes is you're like oh I just
realized I'm choosing this and it's it's
hard to
you know as a father I have to remember
that too I Leela can believe whatever
she wants but it's really beautiful when
to remember when they go through that
like yeah no yes [__] [__] yeah
super important to be like you gotta
choose it yourself yeah at a certain
point yeah did you ever lose your faith
was there ever like I'm not Muslim
uh no never like anything like that I
think is just be being disconnected yeah
or being kind of like drifting drifting
being you know forgetful being in kind
of a state where it wasn't
um
in the Forefront of my thought yeah and
how old are you know I'm 31. okay yeah
you're still a young man it's kind of
not to dismiss the young but I find it
it's really hard to
let's put it this way yeah I find it
gets easier as you get older there's a
certain uh Brokenness yeah you start to
see just a little bit of like slowing
down and decaying that's really helpful
yes to to Humble you and to and to lock
you into something yes focus so there's
certain things everything being possible
is very overwhelming yeah and so at a
certain point you're just like all right
like like I like you know I'm you see it
happen at different stages in your life
but like I'm very thankful that there
weren't you know maybe there were
limitations in my life I never viewed
them unless they really hit me over the
head yeah so like I wanted to play in
the NBA and then like I kept believing
I'd get that growth spurt and then at a
certain point I had to roll it out and
then I'm like okay fine but then at a
certain point I was just like so full of
optimism that I was like well I could do
anything other than playing the NBA you
know and that's still like a really
[__] overwhelming place to be in yeah
you know
the four day shoot older you get you
kind of are like all right like this is
what it really you know there's like
more reality and yeah and actually I'm
32.
next month so I'm gonna say I'm 32
because the reason I say that is because
I infinitely feel 30 and 31 have been
easier than my 20s yeah like in terms of
just like
calming the [__] down like and being a
little more real about like this is
actually what my life looks like yeah
like let me just can I just say I'm 43.
you know it only that yeah it's it's I
hope and then before you know you look
back on your 20s and you're like
there's so much late night eating I know
I know I know like it it really and
that's the struggle it's one of the
reasons I'm glad I did this podcast when
I was you know 10 years younger yeah I
don't want to forget when Leela's in her
20s yeah there was a time when that was
like yeah a good time to go yeah [__]
Lollapalooza or whatever yes yes let me
ask you this
some of the questions that I had
watching the show
um just his conversation is not as like
a speed round yeah it's not a speedrun
does God care if uh your toes are clean
you know what I'm saying like that's a
question your character asks yeah and I
I wrestle with stuff like that too but
like what what are your feelings
um
uh it's a question it's so funny because
we've been making the show
oh yeah I guess there's a lot well no
it's more like like I I wrote that scene
when we shot the pilot in 2017. it's
like six years ago right that I wrote
that and uh and every year in my
personal life that question means
something to me in a different way oh
wow and
um
it's like I think what I've kind of come
so so for anyone who hasn't seen it the
scene is basically
um you know we have a ritual washing we
do before we pray and uh my character in
The Pilot is doing it and part of it is
washing your feet and a guy at the
mosque sees him doing it and says when
you washed your feet you didn't go
between your toes and that means you're
going to hell because if the water
doesn't go between your toes the devil
goes between your toes so this question
of is that really how it is
I pray
and I hope that it's not
you know so that's like and this is a
grill God only knows but I think there's
enough evidence to say that there's a
lot of Mercy that that's not like the
framing but the importance of
what does it really mean to go between
your toes because I think when I first
started making the show
um
I wasn't making fun of going between
your toes but I more was standing from a
place of like yo why is
the faith that I know I because I've
I've felt really connected through
prayer I have like when I bend down on
the ground it is like this like physical
submission into the nothingness and
there's even a part of it that feels
silly like that I'm just like bending
Facing East and then that also helps me
drop any
thought of I'm cool or any thought of
whatever like I literally it's literally
humble frustrated I feel humbled
prostrating yeah yeah and I always felt
really connected to that and then I
always felt like there was this attitude
around gatekeeping getting to do that
because there's so many people saying
this doesn't make you a real Muslim if
you do this this doesn't make your own
so I wrote that scene from a perspective
of how can someone say if you don't go
through the toes you don't get access to
the feeling of transcending that's
[__]
[Music]
but then the years go by and I realize
as I do actually in my real life try to
create different relationships with that
act of prostrating and I wash up before
I pray
when I wash my feet and I wash between
my toes I am inherently more present
right and the connection is way deeper
because I'm slowed down so it's like if
I'm like oh I gotta pray and I'm like
washing you know wash my face real quick
splash water on my feet run into prey
yes that's one way to pray but then wait
no let me stop you know I'm putting some
water like I'm running my fingers
through my toes I'm really thinking
about because so much of the
um the romance or the spiritual kind of
you know guide around washing up before
you pray is like you're washing
everything you did off of you and you
get a new opportunity to restart and you
get that five times a day
yeah yeah and really like you know and
and I lived in La for 10 years and there
was I remember you know getting involved
in a lot of like
I I went to the um David Lynch's you
know meditation
um I went to
um you know a couple of like mushroomy
Ayahuasca type places I only ever did
the tried the shrooms and and that was
later actually it took me a really long
time to actually try I never did
Ayahuasca but um
presence is emphasized so much and I
remember being in one of those circles
where someone was like yeah I do five to
seven daily meditations you know and I
think you look at like um you download
the com app on your phone it's inviting
you to do it multiple times a day the
breath work app is saying hey it's time
for a Breath Right multiple times a day
so we know we need this reset we know we
need this presence and so that between
the toes became to me less about
you know does God care it's more like
well I care about being present to that
connection that's why you know it's like
it's like what can I do to to prepare
for that connection that I care so much
about right it's a to me it would be
about like what I hear you saying I
think
let me just put it my way it's like
God's love is there and there are things
we can do that removes the static from
the radio it didn't actually change
God's love but like you're saying like a
certain posture yes a certain breath yes
a certain food like when you do I
haven't done iOS either but if I did I
would do the Ayahuasca diet because
they're like you shouldn't have like
yeah steak in your stomach yeah yeah you
want to go visit a python yes in your
mind how are you arriving full of steak
you don't want to go to and I actually
had a bad mushroom trip I don't eat meat
but that day for some reason I ate in
and out burger I think it was to impress
a girl and or or fit in yeah and then I
took mushrooms and I was like oh no the
joke I made was I was like the drug I
psilocybin was the medicine I took that
thing yeah the drug I took was in an
outbreak yeah because it just felt so
wrong yes yes to have the blood of a
thousand cows in my stomach I mean
that's like it's a joke yeah it's not
one cow guys that's a thousand cows yeah
uh so anyway sorry that was a little uh
meat tangent but
I hear you it's like C.S Lewis saying
prayer doesn't change God prayer changes
us to that I would add and this might be
too new agey to you when you're
appreciating slowing down and I would
say Waiting for God like a burglar
that's what washing deliberately is or
that's what's dropping in or that yeah
is like getting really right on the edge
of the knife
you who are you deep down I would say
the animating principle of you is
part of God like a I say this a million
times on the show but it's like yeah
you're made of water God's the ocean but
like there's water in you so God is
slowing down and enjoying it as you yes
like that's part of it too meaning
instead of thinking of another thing
over there God
that this also helps with this that's
watching me suffer I like to say God is
suffering with me like to like I am
suffering and God is in my suffering
instead of watching going like wish I
could help you or whatever yeah yeah
involved in all things so when I slow
down I can get into that clean
relationship I love that and I love that
that static too yeah removing that
status yeah just clearing it up it's not
that you were bad yeah it couldn't even
wash yeah I mean you can believe that if
you want to me it's like
it's the same thing as like dimming the
lights or or lighting a candle or
whatever or like like you could
theoretically depending you on how much
there is you could drive which is on the
windshield
but it would be better to not
I've never full Statue of Liberty
just just as many ways as someone would
say you know until this moment I wasn't
sure I hadn't defended you I'm not
offended you just kind of like what a
weird thing to say no it's very relevant
I in L.A dude so many dicks
um I love that yeah there's something
a date
um making love I know that I'm not
trying to mix it but I'm just like the
times that Val and I have had like a
spiritual connection sexually it's like
a very this is all we're doing yes human
what I'm saying a meal just to take sex
because yeah back to your Christian
people get weird about sex yeah food we
can all agree on food the meals where
you're like or tea ceremony like if you
really make a cup of tea
if you really do anything yeah yeah like
a benevolent alien
that's the whole thing that's what we're
trying that's what we're doing
just this conversation yeah of course
just washing your feet is going to put
you in a place yeah to pray and I do
think it's funny you know it reminds me
of that the com app or all these things
are trying to make us uh do things that
are ancient yes and yet still seems so
wacky wacky I was gonna say what I could
do like the Australians yeah but like in
the same way how many of us are learning
that like having a day without your
phone is really great that Shabbat dude
you know what I mean like there's a
reason why these things are happening
and they actually become more relevant
absolutely no we we bounce back and
forth the humans do this it's just like
this is you know
it's it's yeah we're so incredibly
reactionary you know and but I think
that's kind of what we were saying
earlier it's like the Arrogant part is
thinking like oh it's just stupid that
all this tradition has been passed down
you know I think part of the DNA even
when I wanted to make the show was like
I was really interested in that
negotiation of okay I'm looking at this
tradition that I come from what do I
want to keep and what do I want to let
go of you know and kind of watching this
character kind of like in this these
people deal with that very similar you
know it's actually yeah right I was like
what's yes yeah what stays yeah and and
part of that is really just
the more you go through it too you
realize it's like oh what was never even
supposed to be here to begin with yeah
you know because a lot of the junk is
culture yeah yeah and identity yeah and
an ego trip yeah yeah I hear you tell me
about your mushroom experience just
because I couldn't be more interested
you know uh
it's so not that interesting but I'll be
the judge of that no no it was like
it was so not that interesting but very
illuminate it was what I needed I had
been really holding off on doing
anything I've never show you that yeah
at some point yeah and when I wrote that
I hadn't and then I did I think I did
shrooms for the first time after we
maybe even after we did two seasons I
did it for the first time so I'm new to
it I did it like two years ago for the
first time now and um I've been holding
off and I did them with my girlfriend at
the time who's not my wife we got
married and yeah yeah thank you and um
it was
like we we did it cool because we got
this like Tree House in Topanga Canyon
and it was huge it was like this massive
deck you know a big deck overlooking
like you felt like you're just in yes of
course what a great oh no my God no no
and we went early and I hadn't eaten
anything the night before and like like
you're saying like no no prepared yes
and you got to watch your feet before
that yeah like I'm not trying to be
funny no I paid before I did shrooms I
literally was just like yo I wanna like
yeah I want this to be effective in some
way you know and like you know uh
and I think the main thing that happened
to me was first off like I felt my body
totally different for the first time
like I was like aware I was like I'm
taller than I think I am you know I
could feel my back you know and and I
felt this like I was like oh I'm always
scrunching my forehead and and I like I
was on streams and I was like I don't
have to do that like I could feel loose
in my forehead you know like my eyes
could be more open so a lot of it was
really physical and then I think
a lot of it was I just felt this massive
zoom out on my life and and and I had
just finished delivering and releasing
the season and you know what that's like
yeah those periods are really
really stressful that's why I'm so glad
I get to watch Rami because like I've
never seen crash I've just watched Cuts
I just get to watch that it's so fun I
wish you could experience that no it's
you'll never see it every shot is a
memory
that day and all that work yeah and I
was coming out of that but also just
like
I also was someone who for many years I
didn't put anything online I didn't put
any stand up online I was very private
in terms of just like I made some
sketches when I was in high school and
then after that it was like okay I'm
just gonna work on everything alone like
in a room like I don't wanna I'll go to
a comedy club I'm not I didn't you know
what I mean like you're in the stand-up
game you see how everyone does even now
it's way more than even before but like
I out of nowhere basically felt like I
got jolted from uh a private life where
I got to like do things in front of
people to suddenly like a more public
experience that could be kind of
dissected and viewed and I think I was
coming off of the intensity of how that
felt for me
um and this is something I feel all the
time too with artists where it's so
interesting like the the uh and I think
many people in the way that I think
everyone is good I think everyone could
be an artist but like there are like
fewer things in the way of the people
who become artists or they just have a
will where they really can like express
and say certain things
um
and I felt like
we have to be so sensitive in order to
point out certain things and turn them
into something that we offer and then
you're so raw and so sensitive that any
feedback that comes in about it is also
incredibly hurtful or sensitive even if
it's positive it's overwhelming the
sensitivity that enabled you to make art
is the same sensitivity that makes it so
hard to release
It's really because you don't have as
many walls yeah that's right to protect
you right and so I was feeling stressed
and unprotected at the time when I took
it I just had an image of a lobster who
takes off his shell or her shell to make
art with the shell yeah and then all the
other lobsters come and watch and
there's this like naked Lobster
being like I hope there's no Pebbles
floating around this water yeah right
you had that image and you're not even
on shrooms right and that and that's no
one said I don't know and that was
that's actually like to zoom to to fast
forward to like uh after shrooms big
takeaway I had was I can tap into that
state of mind when I'm not on it it
taught me how to get to this place yeah
I made the path in the snow all your
footsteps yeah so much clearer yeah yeah
yeah but yeah when I was in it I I felt
this thing I hadn't felt ever where
um
I I just had to zoom out and and
I was worried about taking any sort of
drug about of it being losing control
and going into something dark and what I
felt on it was it is so amazing that I
don't have control in this moment
um even though I didn't feel out of
control but I just felt like I was
genuinely flowing with what was
happening in a way which is I'm still
present because I think there's this
thing when you think if I don't have
control that means I'm not present but
it's like no no you can be present
without control and that really taught
me that and then I also was in this
place where I was like wow I really
um
everything's okay I don't have to be
I don't have to be so worried yeah yeah
I just saw I just saw everything like I
just had a really warm feeling the whole
time it couldn't have been more positive
for me right yeah right yeah that's
interesting I know exactly what you mean
that it's all happening there's like a
do you make the sun rise do you make it
go down you know what I mean like don't
you see all this this thing that you're
a part of that can be revealed to you
when you really think it's all about you
and it can like you keep saying zoomed
out and you're like no I'm part of a
whole thing you could just call it life
you could call it God you could call it
Leela whatever you want to say but it's
happening yeah and you're a part of it
so I can't believe how self-centered we
are not not even in a bad way like we're
so self-centered we don't even know
we're self-centered yeah that when you
get a moment where you're simultaneously
more in your body but also more
expansive you're just like wow I thought
I was carrying the whole thing it's like
no the sun's gonna go up and down even
if you don't think about it once is that
great it's amazing yes it's what an
amazing system I know and you're being
supported by this couch
I'm sorry I have to plug the couch right
now I'm just kidding hey man the couch
keeps this podcast going this cow is
couch and me undies I don't know what I
don't know what the sponsorships are but
um okay so I I'm we're almost out of
time because I do have yeah what is it
210 okay this is great
um can you tell me a religious
experience you had you kind of alluded
to that it's probably very difficult to
put into words but is there anything
that comes to mind and then I just have
one last question then we'll get out of
here
um you know I just I had this experience
going to Mecca that was you went to
Mexico I went to Mecca yeah I went and
did um there's like two pilgrimages you
can do there's one that's like the Hajj
which is like the big one uh and there's
kind of a smaller pilgrimage called
almra which you can just do at any time
really anytime you can get to Mecca you
can go and do it and um
and I was there and
I just
it was this time where it was so simple
so simply small there was literally like
a petty argument happening between
someone and someone else in my family
and I heard that my aunt like my great
aunt actually But like everyone has kids
so young that she just feels like my
aunt but it's like my mom's aunt but
really my aunt
um was there
and I called someone in the family and I
was like hey can you give me her number
I don't have what number her SIM card is
in Saudi I have her Egypt number but
she's got a Saudi number so I need that
number so I can call her because I want
to see her like we're both in Mecca at
the same time yeah and the person I was
talking to in my family was just kind of
like ah because you could tell there was
like they were upset with her with
someone or whatever and they just like
were like I don't worry about it you
just focus on you being there you don't
have to see her and like hangs up on me
and I'm like
why can't I just get this phone number
why does everything have to be so
complicated why are we so dramatic
and we
were there for I was on this trip I was
there for like three four days and my
luggage never showed up like it just so
I was wearing the same outfit that I
like flew there with and I was about to
go to Medina which is colder so I had to
buy pants and so I had this interaction
where I was trying to get her number I
couldn't get it a day or two goes by and
then I'm sitting in my hotel room and
I'm like I'm going to Medina tomorrow I
need to get pants and I'm like possessed
I'm like I have to go get these pants
and I leave the hotel room I don't even
bring my phone and I just go over to
there's this mall and I go over there
and I'm like I need pants ask someone
and they go go to the store I go to the
store I'm looking in this floor and I'm
like where are the pants and then they
go go up this escalator go up the
escalator and I'm still looking around I
don't know and I just go I'm like trying
to find someone who works there and I go
and I and I go excuse me do you know
where the pants are and as woman turns
around it's my aunt
and if I tell you how many people yeah
are yeah in Mecca
you ever see the pictures
of just people yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this isn't one Woodstock 97. it's it's
this is yeah just yeah yeah
she's right there wow and she's holding
pants yeah
she goes it's Funky Cold Medina you're
going to want to wear this and this is a
story about the best pair of pants I
ever got in my life so these pants are
the material is I would say me undies
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Uggs for thoughts oh wait perfect Gene
perfect Gene there's a perfect Gene the
perfect Gene but it wasn't I wish it was
uh see so it was like it was this um and
I'm telling you there was just this
petty stuff going on the family and we
take this photo together and then and
then I send it to one of my cousins and
now my cousin puts the whole family on
the same like this one thread on
WhatsApp that lives on till today where
everyone talks on this thread just
honestly in a way that we didn't before
so it's not like it was just like it
like it literally was like we're all
communicating in a different closer way
yes none of that stuff got in the way it
was just this really small thing but I
just remember and look there's so many
moments in my life where I just felt
possessed to go somewhere to do
something yeah and it was like changing
and amazing and it was exactly where I
was supposed to be and there's so much
of life that that just again like feels
out of our control and just feels
destined and you know you know this it's
like look at how successful you've been
and you look back at it and you're like
it'd be crazy and be like I chose all of
it and it's all because of me you're
kind of like this whole this is what a
[__] miracle right no it's absolutely
true the way because I have a 30-second
story I walked I was supposed to meet
this agent I was on best week ever at
the time I've told the story a million
times but I love it I was on best week
ever at the time of showing VH1 in New
York and I met I had a general meeting
with this guy named Avi Gilbert and he
was like you got to be Mike birkwoods
who's my agent now but he wasn't at the
time my first manager Avi Gilbert oh
there you go Gotta Be with Avi if you're
in New York
um and he goes
we're gonna have to cut out a lot of
this podcast
sorry just rewind so you can cut this
part out
I walk into Mike bergwood's office and
he's on the phone and he's like he goes
I don't know any comedians that are on
best week ever and he hangs up the phone
and because I walked in the office at
that moment I worked for two years wow
and like what wow that that one that's
my great aunt and yeah it was really
really crazy changed my life yeah it
made me it made me a professional
comedian yes yes I went from yeah no job
to I had a job no that's what you're
just you're supposed to be doing that
that's that's it yeah yeah listen look
for the clues
um look for the clues I say thank you
podcast host this has been awesome we've
had like we've had like so much nuanced
conversation please don't end it on look
for the clues
so much happened that was for the clues
that was really like I got excited
multiple times don't
edit it out leave jizz on the windshield
[__] edit out look for the clues and
it was also like I didn't look at you
look for the clues because I knew it was
bad oh yeah you threw this all away like
just in a you could now I want t-shirts
that's the only way to redeem this we'll
go on a tour called the look for the
clues tour Peter you couldn't control
yourself God that's a Peter moment
that's a Peter Peter Pete didn't do that
no Peter Peter that's Peter
uh the final thing we asked I hate I
could talk to you all day and that's a
high compliment I love this chat I got
very little sleep and I've I've loved
every moment
I'm trying to give you the best
compliment I can
um can you think of the time in your
life you laughed the hardest you've
never laughed harder or anytime you've
laughed really really hard
because it's kind of an on the spot
question here are the prompts it doesn't
have to be a good story yeah yeah yeah
it you could have been a kid don't
forget you might have been a child yeah
a lot of times somebody fell down a lot
of times it's somebody farted sometimes
it's on drugs sometimes it's just a
movie or something but like yeah maybe
it was your siblings maybe it was I
don't know a tickle fight
there's something look for the clues
something recently happened okay I
what was it there's something there's
two things I have in my mind there's one
recently that I'm trying to find I was
laughing so hard I was crying
all right I'll see the one I remember
one like honestly my childhood
was filled with my uncles
like making me laugh until I cried but
it was just from their like Stone Cold
conviction about like whatever it is
they're talking about like my uncle my
one like anything funnier no just it's
why I like it's why I like when we make
the show and it's like with Muslims like
Muslims are just convicted that's why
it's so funny like like you know
religious people just have conviction
they're just like this is what it is and
then and it's so it's so funny to be so
serious me and my friend Kurt I've been
friends with them for
um 20 years yeah we still go it's in the
scriptures it's in the scriptures
because we walked by a guy yelling that
at my at my college it was crazy it just
so like you know and I remember like my
uncle was telling this story once he's
so convicted and so convinced that
Condoleezza Rice and Bill Clinton are
the same person well he probably could
convince you that they just that they
[__] like that's all it was he just was
like and it was like an hour an hour of
just like the proof
and this is why and like and he had his
argument oh it was so ready to go
thought out and it was just and it was
just like why are we talking about this
why do you care so much about it and it
was just it was always stuff like that
like it was just it was just a
conspiracy theory that by the end you'd
walk out and you'd be like why do you
even want to be right about this like
what matters like even if this is true
why did we waste so much time talking
about it like yeah which is really what
makes my uncle the original podcaster
it's like why are we talking about it
even if it was just true
do something why are we talking about
this oh my God this is our podcasts
without absor endings yeah or endings or
a record you just walk away with the
feeling of like am I smarter for those
three hours like you know it's just like
that's being with an uncle you know if
you're a Christian
I mean this was excellent I think we've
had I guess say keep it crispy in uh do
you speak Arabic yeah I think Azhar
Usman might have said it in Arabic oh I
don't even know if I'd know how to say
crispy in here I think he had the same
problem yeah yeah
translate it yeah it doesn't matter we
can just go straight or just use azhars
yeah yeah go back I don't think anybody
will rabbit and just like suddenly like
a very abrupt cut yeah Emmett people
confused us all this do you know us art
dude I bet Mo and us are sort of similar
to just like those big barrels yeah yeah
so ulcers
um a producer on on Rami oh is it yeah
yeah so ozar is like yeah yeah he's I
love it yeah yeah yeah I love Ozzy you
could sell a ketchup popsicle to a woman
in white clubs that's like the most
persuasive
like I know how he's not I know that's
that's the that might have been my
introduction me like selling us no no no
I know flying cars or something no I
know but I the first you made it weird I
listened to was the one you did with him
oh no I remember it was like do you
remember like four hours you got to give
me the faith of of old women yeah that I
I still think about that
God give me the defense yeah and other
will say something like that and I'll
just go
yeah dude's like Paul Bunyan or
something yeah he's like a Mythic no
he's a legend yeah yeah
yeah sure okay so let's put Arabic aside
although I do think it's so cool uh
anytime I have a bilingual friend but
just say would you hit us with the keep
it crispy and thank you so much for that
dude thank you keep it crispy that's how
I feel you keep it crispy thank you
thank you
[Music]